hello welcome back to Nintendo treehouse
live I am Kendra and I'm up here with my
buddies Eric and Ed from treehouse and
we are about to take a look at Legend of
Zelda breadth of the wild we're going to
do some hunting some gathering and we're
also going to check out a new mechanic
where we create temporary hearts so take
it away well so we're going to get to
the nitty-gritty in this segment the
hunting and gathering systems are really
sophisticated or I'm going to get
after i take out this this pheasant he's
hiding up here catholic insist
because it's the first time i picked
this up it's going to
gotta be so quiet oh yes nice so I'm
just gonna go grab a perfectly prepared
piece of meat it is Justin sick bird
meat drumstick what's not starting ok so
to start I'm just gonna take a look at
my surroundings so I see here I'm blog
hardy truck so this is something we're
going to cook a little bit later too
give us some temporary hearts but first
I am so let's find some animal I love
how you're just strolling everywhere hey
you have to sneak up on them you do it's
here where you later bekasi 40 s / thurs
so far oh nice Oh States severe they
will always drop to the States but I
have two mistakes
I can eat this Romney Iranians coming
this little one art but i can also
prepare it
that's piyah here
put something more gravy sauce up some
party truffle right mr. MELAS serum and
heart and truck
so all of these all of these foods have
certainly always to them like I said you
can draw out specific elements of them
through the preparation through the
cooking process so it's sort of
gathering as much as you can get all
that one's up front it's really
beneficial here I'm Jessica gonna head
shot these guys nice nice and it's not
too hard to find food all throughout the
forests and everywhere you go there are
different things that you can collect
yes so I actually just picked up with
butter flavor if I use that to prepare
it mixing some monster hearts in our
community go check out
right now I'm kind of gathering all this
and then I'll see
look at all you gotta get your
ingredients but as we're traveling from
place to place in the game they've gotta
have to talk see the punish your hearts
so in previous elbows were able to cut
down the grass and put your hearts back
in this game you can't invent you have
to go are you not to cut what you're up
to date night cooking usually increases
how many hearts
but what you can do
graph is sometimes when you cut down
longer grass fine
I love something
so if I
little buddies hanging out and I think
something up know also is you know
you're going on this boar hunting
rampage because that's your style but
you can also do a vet you play through
on this you know there's no own business
there's no need to do that because
there's so many other forms of food and
sustenance that you can gather in the
game yeah and a lot of the veggie dishes
that you can prepare have ton of
benefits to them so it's always worth
exploring
oh gosh this guy is not having it all oh
my god nice
ignore your way
hope you and all the way
did I pick up this
drugs
ok check out some fries let's see what
see if we can get some frogs
some stuff gets more
right so metal complexes out for
those prepare that with Miss Lisa
we're happy to
venue
so special
no froggies
explore in the high graph here see if
there any into the hollow yes cricket so
you can also combine that with
can you find different stuff whether
it's in the grass also you'll find
different animals at different time
today
fireflies which have special effects
that you're afraid
Oh
so let's take me for
fire right
and let's get to cook so I'm go friend
sorry I have three states the first
thing I'm just going to eat
but if i were to either it's got to give
me one heart and what i can do is I'm
going to hold it and there multiple ways
to search right here i have campfire and
i have a so what i can do is i can
either hold the torch to this drop it
straight on the fire it's going to turn
the steak cook it and it's going to be
calm
so that's going to give me a heart and a
half but I could take that same
ingredient rustic
straight cooking is so much easier in
this game than in real life he makes it
look so easy sticks that's gonna be too
hard so that's double the amount of help
it's alright and obviously you're not
always going to have access to certain
pot all right
do general we always have access to fire
they're at least you want to try to
write so I can actually hold up to five
items different recipes in scalar crazy
he's having difficulty can combine
to get different fish right now gonna
mix the steak with
three hearty truckers to have them all
in my hand here and drop the one thing I
really enjoy about my own gameplay that
I've had is you can combine a lot of
elements that in the real world would
make sense and then they they turn into
amazing recipes so you can apply
real-world logic to it it's really cool
so i just made a meal i'm also going to
so I Mexico
is no problem
yo soy take yum yum real world yeah
exactly here we go that's me
internationalism so I can drink that to
restore like if I was climbing at about
to run out of stamina I'm able to drink
that and restore some Stan but to make
it I came the moment yeah it was super
helpful they're all so there's all sorts
of these elixirs and deals you can make
that will you know power up your attack
power making run faster stealth stealth
give you an extra part of your stamina
wheel that's what I said actually like
the stuff what would be nice don't
guessing about these stealthy gradients
I'm not having stuff but I did cook this
this hearty meat much so it's going to
fully recover my hearts and then add
three additional hearts that are
temporary so those last so they've taken
away my obviously a monster so making
dishes like that are really useful for
super strong enemies that you'll
inevitably encounter I always make sure
to have my entire menu just filled with
those just tons of them they're super
helpful if you're going on a big boss
battle yeah encounter and it makes me
feel safe makes me feel safe having
those in my inventory that's what's
important yeah so one thing I did
mention is you actually obviously don't
have to get ready Hannibal's you could
just like the hospice route yep yeah
good you could look around mushrooms
truck
you can just hug trees like this and do
whatever you want okay you can't get
through the entire game that way if you
want nice
so I can use that Flint so I have this
kind of portable fire starter right so
if I was out in the middle of nowhere
and I just like had a really nasty
encounter with Aneesa regularly I would
be able to
I'm gonna pull this what cutters acts
out that perfectly bundle yet again
so what it can do
is I'm going to take the bat
fire hold it off the hope of twin I'm
going to drop it right here let me take
any metallic weapon right this way
that's
oh that is non metallic oh thanks I just
suddenly have a fire and cook on I can
warm you up yeah you know if I was I
think happy right here to be amiss
hold this level yeah in higher altitudes
yeah and so I can also cook things to
increase my homework
so I'd be able to grab some spicy
peppers its number with some steak in
mid code responsive state then you got
yourself a skewer yes that's fewer I
would see a ghoulish is a fish down
there so one thing I love bringing this
video is online yes so I'm going to toss
that bomb come on Lenny over there
check it out fish that come and go sort
of it's based on the time of day what
are their actually around or not you go
hey that is our thing you just get a
soup out of it alright so i can take
that you're not so you know Spearfish
for sure
the bumper stickers is so true
I'm going to grab this recevoir could
make
whoa
so if I run out stamina while Swilley
kind of makes like a gurgling noise and
floats down into the water it's the
sports lake
you really have to plan out when you're
when you're trying to climb something or
swim swim somewhere you have to really
think about it and look at your stamina
gauge before you do it because otherwise
you will really end up in a bad
situation
paragliding down here
beckylyn support black sea tarde oh man
i was out in it he heard what you did do
is a buddy Gary before come back there
run little more Kendra's cheering for
the boar why are you coming back
this is of course the ancient art of
sore throwing that's you what this time
I'll be back didn't make it through the
ages and if you if you were to land that
it would have dealt more damage than
just shooting the arrow act a lizard the
high Taylor that if I were to use that
to the perimeter that's going to give me
to increase sweet boost for moving right
so you can do high tail lizard and
they're like mushrooms you know what I
don't know that's I don't think I've
done that yet well honey wizards the
insects reptiles so that's actually we
did that never that would give you okay
we should do that and just like in real
life they are extremely persistent oh
they're not so chasing you
just love the ambient sounds
whoops
and it's falling out hollow it out
the level of detail that careless to
give an ounce to make it feel alive
stop
yeah I mean you were talking about sort
of the depth of the cooking mechanics
and I remember when we were we had video
conference with the dev team and they're
like hey so here's here's the list of
all the foods that make with all the
items and she's mad will sit document
there like you want that translator
where uh no a few documents I don't know
what we do okay so what's coming to you
scam definitely makes me hungry every
time I play I was gonna be totally gross
we were aiming something bad yeah okay
so how so you made all these wonderful
things some guys just replace hearts it
replace hearts and some that give you
certain abilities and new properties but
but this time I'm going to take what is
that a bird wing of mushroom papal power
thing
a butterfly is the bunch of stuff it
created yeah I'm yep oh wait that worked
hey name is one ok I spicy Lou alright
awesome ok sweet what's that wasn't
grocery everything you have is tasty
festival that is the problem you need to
go find some strategy suck the gross
things
I'm here just picked up your wish
Charlie's in an acorn I mean acorns are
the tastiest entire brother play bass
butterfly oh there we go what the sound
sir yes sir yes sir we can't even look
at it stop that's that guys ok so that's
your failure and the best thing you kind
of have to experiment fine with any
users which one and you can still eat it
and it's dope right now so yeah a little
bit yeah it's what one heart I think
we're playing yeah and what school is
like you can spend all this time hunting
and picking intent finding out it would
make it on the list as you're moving
from place to place kind of find the
things that you
you don't have to necessarily go out of
your way it's always be hunting and
gathering yeah yeah as you explore you
just run into all kinds of things you
can collect
like that's 70 check it out
Kristen those were my I leash so my gosh
see it detects disarm to attack you I
funny is I'm not wait yes I like that
you're right prioritizing the mushrooms
two is you're ready Brad you're like I
gotta collect these have its importance
ok so i wish i'm gonna made myself like
speakers sir
yes spicy elixir ain't gonna do much for
us there but temporary hurts so we've
got one skewer yeah we go so oh boy this
step towel is one of the one of the
major enemies on the fence out here okay
clears weak spot thanks
one thing I love about this game too is
that you'll be walking around will be
all peaceful you're just like ahh and
then all of a sudden this monster just
emerges from the earth it's like that's
like throwing it's all about you so
actually just got wrecked in one shot
where this guy so I hid his weak spot
enough where it starts feeling he'd rape
he dropped a very precious mineral so be
able to pick that up and either sell
that in the first of the game but so
he's big and bad he's thinking about we
weren't prepared right so I didn't have
very strong weapons and also I have
obviously started gear come on
addressing the game they're going to get
here with way higher defend rights and
all that and that's what's so cool about
this game is it throws a lot of those so
the conventions I window while keeping
part ii but having spats two gears
that's like it I wouldn't necessarily
say you were unprepared you just wanted
the challenge you wanted to do it in a
challenging way yeah challenging it
exactly right away yes you can do but
you can do it anyway yeah you really can
yeah I'm in there multiple ways good
some people like that showers of the
Gateway for me the more satisfying thing
is seeing something that I know I'm not
prepared for and then gearing up coming
back coming back later and being like
this ultra powerful you scare me but now
it's gonna write the all-powerful link
but you know kind of what your touch
earlier it's like you know you can go in
there with super wait gear and if you
got like food or properties or an elixir
that gave you speed boost like suddenly
you're much more agile and nimble when
you're fighting that huge piece and so
that gives you like a whole nother area
sort of a leg up when you can still use
Boko clubs and you know the poplin arms
or whatever it is really as long as
you're really think so it's definitely
worth taking the time to cook oh yeah I
love that the physics engine just seeing
Rick crumpled bling crackdown where I
college I feel like leak is hungry very
hungry he's so hungry right now
thanks
okay so I need you
oh this is a perfect time there we go so
i should actually pop that before I
before going oh those that's all right
okay
because now this takes you out of one
fat territory perhaps
and you'll find different famous all
you pick up rocks let me know
fucku truck pick up again where'd you go
oh she's vanished so that hot pastrami
verify frogs hmm r if I use that like so
that's going to give you and these
always able
except Chuck you know we talked about it
before this morning but you know it
really is when you start talking about
the cooking and gathering mechanic there
it really gets you thinking about how
many different ways you can manipulate
the environment and use these resources
that are there to your advantage in so
many different ways it's such an awesome
new addition this all the universal love
it
Rocky's right huggies me
ah
what
get the fire going it's my time fancy
yeah
forest fire good
so at night time because of the 24th day
night cycle actually at night time the
temperature does drop mmm so depending
on where you are it may put you over
that threshold where you going to start
taking damage and that's where you would
need something I'm question I can find
all those ingredients and now i have the
spicy elixir I drink this he's going to
give me cold resistance 49 minutes 0
seconds that's gonna she's a very
substantial amount of time of game yet
wherever it was okay
and you can kind of sequence me names no
open you can honestly do things
that poor is still angry about his buddy
Gary yeah he's still angry that's the
guy again there is all right let's see
if any
I mean some of that what I should have
done it okay stop
so this
super
that's right yeah baby
he's pleased I combined the two but it
actually didn't give me this give me
heart
again it's not necessarily one-to-one
like this about trial-and-error
experimentation oh yeah
I found myself just like filling links
arms with everything in my inventory all
at once and then just dumping it in
there and doing that repeatedly and
actually made a lot of really good
dishes I'm surprised
something about growing weapon so
satisfied especially when you we're down
to one pitch you throw it that's
guaranteed critical
seen it shatter fresh damage across the
back obelisk or head it's always worth
that risk
mrs. Borik and running around
Oh coming phone clicks so excited to see
you it just barely made it up for the
wall
very nice smitty's frenzy sneaky here
what's the
Oh
so now these four coppers here actually
chasing this floor
I like to go into sniper mode stand
really far back and just they don't even
know where it's coming from i see i love
this they're going after that they're
going after that for now but they're
living their own the cobbler lives
they're hungry too yeah what you're just
doing their own thing I really feel for
the pores
because so do that
oh yes
alright that's just about all we have
time for thank you so much for watching
the hunting and gathering section
Nintendo treehouse live at e3 and stay
tuned to check out shrine up next